yeah the margarita of course is a
classic cocktail but do you know where
the drink
comes from jc fernandez is live at ha
songs
mexican tantina i hope i said that right
in boca park with the back story of how
you can get one
for free today hey jc did i say that
right
it's who songs oh my god that's what
you're saying who songs rocky
i had two choices
that's okay it's okay margaritas fix
everything and the margarita actually
started
at who songs not here in the las vegas
location but this is heidi what is the
backstory
on the on the the margarita how did it
start
the original margarita was at our
ensenada location it was invented in
1941.
a beautiful diplomat's daughter came in
named margarita henkel
she sat down at the bar and the
bartender made her this drink
of crushed ice fresh lime
fresh agave a little bit of a salted rim
and she loved it and she was so
beautiful that we named the drink after
her that is what if her name was karen
we've been drinking cairns all these
years but i'm with margarita and we love
it and it's your 11th year
it's your 11th anniversary here in las
vegas tell everybody about the two
specials that you have
so today we have our happy hour nachos
for five dollars
all day and bogo margaritas buy one get
one free who doesn't yes
okay we all love that buy one get one
free and they do have curbside
pickup as well and you have your
mixologist let's watch you make your
magic here we have 30 seconds left
do your magic and make us a beautiful
margarita heidi what's going into this
so this is our fresh lime we've got
triple sec
agave tequila now you have to have
plenty of tequila in there because if
there's not enough tequila it's not a
good margarita that's right you're right
you want to feel nothing after that
margarita no no and then she's going to
shake it up
perfect perfect i like it i like it
margarita mixologist right here
and that's it right there good to go and
of course you can either salt the room
or leave the salt plain right
absolutely yeah we go with salt it's
much better with salt i like a little
salty perfect well happy anniversary
here's a little fun fact
the normal 11th anniversary is steel
that's the gift
i like how you're giving us the gift of
margaritas and nachos today
come down to his songs two locations are
also at mandalay bay as well
here in boca park we'll send it back to
you guys in the studio
yeah i'll take it thanks j.c